foreign
flickers of fear so in my last movie
review uh which if you remember was a
knight of the demon AKA curse of the
demon from 1957.
um and I figured that since I had
finally got around to seeing you know
that kind of iconic movie from the 1950s
that I had previously been uh sleeping
on much to my shame I decided that for
this movie I was gonna go kind of go
like continue along the same lines I
guess you know and finally get around to
seeing a movie from also from the 1950s
that gets brought up a lot like in the
horror Community even though it's not
technically a horror movie it's kind of
more a thriller
um but this was a movie that I just kept
hearing about there's so many references
to it like in other movies and things
like that so I was like I really need to
get around to watching this and this is
the 1955 movie The Night of the Hunter
and like I said it's not really I guess
it has horror elements to it for sure
but it's kind of considered more like a
Noir Thriller but it really is kind of
like horror adjacent and I just feel
like I had to get around to seeing it so
I finally did now this movie was
actually based on a novel
by Davis Grubb and the novel was
actually inspired and I actually didn't
know this until I started researching
this uh this video was that the novel
was actually based on a real guy
um a dutch-born serial killer named
Harry Powers who later immigrated to the
United States and he was like this
lonely hearts style killer
um he would do the thing where he would
like run personal ads like you know for
marriage and stuff like that in
newspapers like you did back in the
1920s and 1930s and he would Target
widows specifically and then he would
you know try like basically lure them
into his web kill them and take all of
their money now they think that he
murdered I think he was convicted
ultimately of five murders but they
think he may be killed more than that
like maybe at least two more and much
like the fictional serial killer in that
you see in Night of the Hunter he was
actually eventually hanged uh for his
for the murders and he was hanged in
Moundsville West Virginia in the 1930s
now the movie adaptation the night of
the Hunter
it was actually directed by uh the actor
Charles Lawton who's of course very very
famous
um he was also married to you know the
Bride of Frankenstein herself Elsa
Lanchester and he had also previous to
this directed a bunch of like theater
Productions was mostly his thing now the
night of the Hunter and this this was
another thing that I didn't know this
was his first film director's credit
um unfortunately it was also his last
one because the critical and audience
reaction to the night of the hunter was
so negative that he basically said [__]
it I'm never you know directing another
film ever again and he never did so why
was the reaction so negative uh I
wondered now the source of the problem
and maybe there were other factors going
on in this too but the the source seemed
to be twofold I feel like on the one
hand
um religious audiences seemed like they
were very very offended by the fact that
the villain of the movie was a nominal
preacher
um even though it's made pretty clear
like in the course of the story that
he's only posing as a preacher like he's
not really a real like officially
sanctioned one
another thing I think maybe
um to its detriment at least from a
critical and audience standpoint was
that Charles Lawton had wanted the movie
to not look like a movie from the 1950s
he wanted to like hearken back to like
the old days of silent film so the movie
was a lot more stylized than audiences
at the time were used to seeing I guess
um it definitely was heavily influenced
by expressionism and it was shot almost
entirely on sound stages like even the
exteriors and it shows but it's like
really kind of cool because like I said
it gives it like a look all its own and
it also kind of featured dialogue that
was kind of maybe like over dramatic or
maybe like unrealistic in a lot of ways
maybe like overtly theatrical so I guess
like these all of these things combined
uh kind of kept people away from seeing
it and uh contemporary critics also
really didn't seem to get it either but
I will say that time has been very kind
to this movie
um and the movie is obviously now
considered just like a stone cold
classic and it shows up on a number of
greatest American films of the 20th
century lists and pretty much anyone
that you want to look at will have this
on it at least in my opinion I think
that uh because it you know it had such
controversial subject matter at least
for the time and it's sort of unusual
stylistic like visual choices I kind of
feel like the movie seems a lot less
dated than maybe other you know beloved
films from the 1950s and when I was
watching it I admit that I was really
surprised at how much the movie got away
with for the 1950s I mean especially in
regards to
um some kind of like sexual overtones
and also like some very very real
threats like perpetrated against
children which were like pretty [__]
up and overt so the story of the night
of the hunter is set during the Great
Depression and so I feel like there's
this whole like undercurrent of poverty
and Desperation and it's really um which
really kind of like adds to the horror
and like the tragedy of the main
narrative so at the beginning of the
movie we meet the antagonist of the
piece who is a traveling Reverend by the
name of Harry Powell and he's actually
played by Robert Mitchum and this is a
great performance very very charismatic
um and just like very sexually alluring
but also like very menacing so it's just
really really he's just a great
character like a great villain now from
the jump we are under absolutely no
illusions that this is a very very bad
man uh pretty much within the first five
minutes a group of little boys like find
the body of a dead woman in a barn and
it's revealed that Harry has killed her
stolen her money and a car and just kind
of like taken off for the next town
now uh iconically Harry has the letters
of love and hate tattooed on his
knuckles like on his right and left
hands and this has been homage in
numerous other films and TV shows and
stuff like that so if you ever see
somebody with like love and hate or like
stuff on there tattooed on their
Knuckles this is where it comes from so
Harry gets arrested for the car theft
though not for the murder they didn't
catch him for that and he gets like
thrown in the clink for 30 days I think
it was now while all of that is going on
over here over here we're also following
a family the Harpers now the dad Ben
Harper who's actually played by Peter
Graves he's um you know it's the
depression he's hurting for cash and he
doesn't really want his two kids going
hungry he just hates to see it so he
kind of maybe unwisely uh Robs a Bank
and ends up killing two men in the
process I don't remember if they were I
don't know if they were like people in
the bank or if they were like his
Confederates and he killed him so he
could have all the money it's not really
clear
so so he does that and he's taken off
the cops are on his tail though but
before he gets arrested which he does
um he hides the 10 grand that he stole
and the only person that he tells where
it is is his son John who's looks like
he's about 10 11 something like that
now he makes John swear never ever ever
tell anybody where this money is not
even your mom and look after your
younger sister his name is Pearl
um and then he gets hauled away in
handcuffs now Ben he gets sentenced to
hang but before he gets executed he
actually shares a cell with Harry Powell
who had gotten arrested earlier for the
car theft now Harry Powell has heard
about this bank heist and so he attempts
to kind of like wangle the location of
the money out of bed because he knows
that they never found the cash
um now Ben will not tell him anything
but one night while he's asleep he
mumbles something like a Bible verse
about like a little child she'll lead
them
and so Harry decides that after he gets
out of jail he's gonna just you know
Mosey on over and offer his condolences
to Ben's Widow Willa who's played by
Shelley Winters and hopefully find out
like where all of that money might have
gotten off to so Harry Powell shows up
in this town and just immediately like I
said he's very charismatic so he ends up
like just Charming the dungarees off
everybody in this town with his you know
rugged good looks and charm and his real
passionate religious speeches one of
which which he does a couple of times
has to do with the right and left hand
like why he has those tattoos on his
knuckles like the love defeating hate
all that other kind of stuff which is
really ironic because he's a [__]
serial killer but you know what I mean
now Willa's boss at the ice cream shop
where she works whose name is icy which
I guess I'm just maybe that's not her
real name I just named her that because
she worked at ice cream shop but her
name is icy and she's played by Evelyn
Varden and she is just immediately
completely I mean she's an older lady
but she gets immediately like Mitten
with this mysterious Reverend he's just
blown into town and she straight up
encourages Willa you need to get in
there and jump on that dick before one
of the other women in town like snaps it
up like you know you can't raise two
kids on your own like your husband just
got hanged you need to like move on with
your life and she so I see pretty much
like shoves Willa at this dangerous
serial killer so you know thanks for
nothing you [__] old bat now the only
person in town it seems who isn't fooled
by Harry's very Godly veneer is John the
sun who immediately knows that there is
something intensely sketchy about this
[__] and correctly deduces that
he's just looking for the money that his
dad stole and hid now despite his
obvious hatred for this dude his mom
pretty much almost instantly like within
minutes like marries him uh and this is
a decision which will a spoiler alert
for a very very old movie um end up
costing her her life so it's their
wedding night
Harry implies that Willa is a [__] he
doesn't like say it outright but he like
dances around it you know what I mean
and he tells her also in no uncertain
terms that they will not be having sex
ever because sex is only for procreation
and she already has two kids and she
doesn't want anymore so that's there's
gonna be no banging right so let's just
get that out of your [__] little head
right now because Willa is so kind of
like shocked by this and she's kind of
[__] up I mean it's only been like
five minutes it's like her husband got
hanged pretty much I mean I don't know
how long it wasn't like the universe of
the movie but it's like five minutes in
the movie movie
so Willa decides I guess as sort of like
a shield like for her emotions or
something oh well God told me
that Harry married me in order to save
my soul so it's like so it's fine so
it's good that we're not having sex it's
all this is what the Lord wants you know
what I mean so then she starts
accompanying him on all his tent
revivals that he's doing around the
place and just starts belitting
belittling herself like talking about
how much of a horse it was they don't
she doesn't use that word obviously it's
the 1950s but you know that's the
implication and just kind of like
praising the Lord along with everybody
else
not too long after this though she
actually overhears Harry straight up
threatening her daughter Pearl who is
little she's like five or six
um to tell him where the money is
and even though you would think that
this would snap Willa out of her very
sad and bizarre fantasies that she's
having about this dude saving her soul
it almost seems to make her like more
resigned to her fate I guess because she
basically just lays there's a great
scene and like I said you can tell this
is very very strongly influenced by
expressionism because it's just like
this these Stark shadows and like just
the way the the room looks like the
angles of the room and stuff like that
looks very much like it's like an old
silent film like Nosferatu or something
and so she's basically just like laying
there in bed her and Harry are like kind
of having an argument he goes over there
and straight up like smacks across the
face and she just kind of lays there all
beatific like with the light shining on
her and then he slashes her throat
pretty much I mean they don't show that
but you know you find out that's what
happened later on they just show him
like doing the knife and stuff like that
and then it just cuts to something else
so then Harry like you know kind of
fastens the body to the family car and
just pushes the whole hang into the
river and afterward he tells icy and
just the other townspeople that Willa
this wanted and faithless [__] she just
uh up and took off in the middle of the
night probably to go bang some other
dude somewhere it's like that's what
he's talking about it's like bad enough
that he killed her and then he's like
posthumously like ruining her reputation
like he's the [__] worst
um and honestly like he lays the grief
on so thick like that he's oh my God
he's just so heartbroken that she's gone
and I was gonna help her and all this
other kind of crap I mean he just it's
he's laying it on Thursday it's really
obvious that he's bullshitting but every
single one of these like stupid old
people these clucking old bitties in
town they just like [__] laugh it
right up because of course he's just a
wonderful human being and she just
didn't know what she had and she just
like took off and I was just like oh man
it's just like oh no it was like it was
basically like that level you know what
I mean so meanwhile there is this local
codger named Birdie Steptoe and he's
also friends with John like they he
takes some fish in and stuff like that
now he ends up during one of his fishing
trips seeing Willa's body like at the
bottom of the river while he's out
fishing
um this visual actually is easily the
creepiest of the movie
um this they have like the camera just
like lingering on her body like you know
kind of Trapped in this car and like her
hair is just kind of like swishing in
the water like along with like the river
reads and stuff like that it's actually
like really grotesque and like really
beautiful and like even though the
effect was done with a mannequin like
the mannequin is actually realistic
enough
um that the whole thing is like really
unsettling like because I wasn't sure I
was sure it was a mannequin because I
was like that can't be like Shelley
Winters like just being that still like
in the water but it was so good that
like Tom came in and he was like
watching a little bit too and he's like
wait is that really hurts like is that a
mannequin that looks like a real person
so it's like they did a good job with
that but yeah that's like a really
creepy like iconic scene from this movie
so birdie who is a nice lovely man but
is also a drunk
um he's actually afraid to go to the
police because he thinks that he's gonna
get blamed for the murder and he's like
a little bit traumatized by finding it
you know so instead um he does what what
a drunk do and just kind of like dives
into the bottom of the bottle and like
laments that he can't go to the police
because he'll get blamed like while he's
talking to a picture of his dead wife
meanwhile
again John and pearl are left alone now
with Harry Powell they don't know their
mom is dead they just think they you
know that she ran off but John suspects
it's like this [__] did
something to her but they don't know for
sure but nobody else in town like
suspects Harry Powell of anything which
is really alarming
so Harry just now that there's nobody
around to like stop him he pretty much
straight up threatens like the kids you
better tell me where the money is
um you know or I'm gonna like [__]
kill you or whatever because Jon is
afraid that um that Harry is Gonna Hurt
Pearl the little girl John agrees okay
I'll tell you where the [__] is but he
lies about it because he's not dumb you
know what I mean
um now at this point like for a long
time you don't actually know where the
money is but by this point in the movie
which is kind of about the two-thirds
Mark
um you know that the movie is or the the
money is actually like stuffed inside of
this doll that Pearl has been carrying
around like for the whole movie
um but John tells Harry that it's
underneath this Stone in the basement
but once they're down there like Harry
finds out that you know obviously the
money isn't under there and he actually
like this was the scene that I was kind
of like shot I was like wow um this
really went there but yeah so he like
pushes John's like head down this Barrel
or something he's just gonna like slit
his throat like that because he lied to
him and [__] like that I was like holy
crap so it's 1955 y'all it was pretty
hardcore for that time
but uh but actually John is able to get
the upper hand like he ends up dropping
this heavy shelf it has like all these
like mason jars of stuff and like kind
of drops it on the dude's head and like
knocks him over for a second and then he
just grabs Pearl and like they just get
the [__] out of out of there now they
initially seek help at Birdie's place
but he's so hammered that he's like
absolutely no help at all so they at
this point they're kind of forced to
come up with a plan B now at this point
I think there's about a third of the
movie remaining it's not a super long
movie or anything like that I think it's
about hour 40 minutes hour 47 minutes
something like that but at this point
like the movie changes gear a tad
because the kids actually end up taking
off in their dad's jon boat and all they
have is the doll with the money in it
and just the clothes on their backs they
don't have anything else so they just
kind of drift down the river for a while
every now and then stopping somewhere
and getting an apple from somebody like
it's the depression so a lot of people
are just kind of like well I can only
give you one potato which you know what
I mean it's that kind of [__] now uh so
they're kind of off trying to find some
place to go
and meanwhile Harry Powell uh stabs a
gypsy steals the guy's horse and starts
to hunt for the kids
now the kids eventually turn up at the
house of this kind of like no-nonsense
woman named Rachel Cooper who's actually
played by Lillian Gish now this role was
was initially supposed to go to Elsa
Lanchester who's Charles Lawton's wife
obviously
um but for whatever reason she decided
the last minute she didn't really want
to be in the movie so she recommended
they get Lily English instead so they
did now Rachel actually like I said it's
the depression there's a lot of orphaned
children um you know a lot of runaways
stuff like that so Rachel takes in stray
children like into her house and she um
you know very lovingly takes care of
them and kind of like puts them to work
they pick peaches on her farm and stuff
like that
so John and Pearl at this point very
thankful to become the latest additions
to her large brood
but it doesn't take too long before
Harry Powell tracks them down I mean
they couldn't go that far it's only been
like a day or two and all they had was
this little boat they didn't have any
food or anything
so he shows up at Rachel's house and
claims to be the children's dad now
Pearl runs right to him like a little
[__] traitor I mean she's just like a
little girl so it's just kind of like
ooh father figure you know what I mean
she's not like thinking about it too
hard but I mean still I was like you
shitty little child but God damn it he's
terrible he's a terrible person what are
you doing but John is just like not
having it and he says to like Rachel is
like that's not my father and like the
way he says it Rachel for her uh you
know in her defense she just totally is
like oh this kid is like knows what
what's up like what the deal is so she
knows that this quote-unquote preacher
is absolutely not to be trusted and she
goes and like runs his ass off with a
shotgun and I was like God damn it all
right she's like you don't come back on
here and I'm just like all right we we
like this lady but Harry is not gonna
give up the 10 grand that easily I don't
know uh so he very menacingly like Parks
himself outside the house all night
singing this hymn that he's been singing
like throughout the whole uh movie which
is called leaning on the Everlasting
arms which is real him obviously
um just kind of keeping everybody in the
house awake now Rachel sits up all night
like with the gun across her [__]
knees man she's just like not letting it
happen
um but at one point I just like one of
the other kids like one of the other
girls who's like a teenager she comes in
with a lamp and like she can't see out
the window for a minute and during this
period like Harry just kind of like
melts into the shadows and then he kind
of like sneaks around the side of the
house and like busts in the house right
now again to her credit Rachel who is a
badass uh she just does not hesitate and
she just blasts him she's like she
doesn't give a warning or not she's like
blam and I was like all right again I
really like this lady
um now he isn't killed I don't know if
it's just birdshot or whatever but he's
wounded bad enough that he just goes
hightailing it to the barn like just
screeching and Howling and then Rachel
this is so epic she just very very
calmly like calls the police and she's
like hey police like something is
wounded in my barn and I just like I
just like busted up laughing at that at
that line read it was just so great and
the way she called him is something it's
just I don't know the tone of her voice
just like made me laugh really hard
so the cops come and he's still wounded
bad enough that he hasn't been able to
run off so they take him into custody
but because his arrest looks almost
identical to the arrest of John's father
Ben at the beginning of the movie like
the kid when he sees it happen like they
put the guy down on the ground and
they're putting the cuffs on him and
everything like that so the kid kind of
has like a PTSD flashback or like a
nervous breakdown or something and he
starts like screaming for the police
don't take him don't take him and then
he starts like beating the doll on the
ground and like all the money comes out
and then at Harry Powell's trial like
they put Jon on the stand but he can't
bring himself to testify against Harry
he just like sits there and won't answer
any questions like he's all [__]
traumatized and stuff
um even though he now knows for certain
that this man definitely killed his mom
and they imply that he might have killed
as many as like 25 other women as well
um I mean the kid he went through a lot
so I guess we got to cut him some slack
but still I think that did kind of like
infuriate me I'm like say something kid
God damn it but I guess they were trying
to like you know that he was so
traumatized that seeing it happen again
that he just like clammed up or whatever
um and it turned out that his testimony
was not really necessary anyway because
Harry is sentenced to hang and you know
uh good riddance although it does appear
that the townsfolk which are led by Icy
remember her
um they're gonna [__] Lynch the dude
right like she gets a whole Lynch Mob
going they March through the streets
carrying torches and you know shrieking
for his blood like they're chasing
frankincense monster it's like a whole
deal but uh they don't end up getting
the guy like they they take Harry like
into the car and it's implied although
it's not shown that um Harry actually
meets his end all official like like at
the end of The Hangman's rope and it's
the same hangman that hung Ben at the
beginning but he's like oh well this
time I'm gonna enjoy it because this guy
really is a [__] so like I said
the night of the hunter
um it really is kind of like a standout
film for the 1950s I mean not only in
just this real exaggerated kind of
throwback to the silent era look to it
which is phenomenal it's really
beautiful but also how Grim the
storyline is now I did have a couple
small issues with it um the acting
performances of the kids were kind of
uneven especially like the little girl I
mean she's the child acting was really I
feel like didn't get good until like
much more recently uh so you do see like
a lot of that you know there were some
good child actor performances in the
1950s and in every era but um these kids
were a little a little Hit or Miss
especially the little girl so that was a
thing
um I didn't love how quick it was uh you
know the lead up to Willa and Harry
getting married like I thought that was
like like went by too quickly and also
her deciding that she was gonna be like
you know convert to his cause or
whatever like I kind of feel like that
should have been fleshed out a little
bit more because it was just kind of
short shrift given to that
um and also I gotta say there is a
bewildering over abundance of people in
this movie like singing hymns there's a
lot of singing in this like I wouldn't
call it a musical but there are a lot of
points where people are like singing and
stuff like that which I thought was kind
of bizarre
but other than those like tiny nitpicks
this is a really really compelling movie
you can see why a lot of people like
talk about it why it turns up on so many
lists and stuff like that I mean the
cinematography is just beautiful very
eerie
um and it does have like a lot of
genuine suspense and the villain is
actually very very villainous and you're
just like yeah he's gonna [__] flip
that kid's throat you know what I mean
which is [__] up like especially for
the 1950s and you know I mean Robert
Mitchum is phenomenal as he's easily the
best part of this movie
um he's just like I said he comes across
as so alluring and yet also like really
really obviously very dangerous and like
super super evil I mean he has like no
redeeming qualities whatsoever
um now the whole tone of this movie and
I don't think I'm the first person to
notice this but it comes across very
much like a dark fairy tale is how it
seems because it's a little bit hyper
real you know what I mean like it's not
entirely realistic so it's almost kind
of like it has a little bit of a stage
play kind of uh feel to it as well but I
definitely do think that Charles Lawton
was trying to make it like a fairy tale
like it was structured kind of like that
so I have to say that I mean anybody
that has just even a passing interest
with genre Cinema from the 1950s
um probably needs to give this a look if
they haven't seen it
um it's such a cultural Touchstone and
it's been referenced and homage and like
so many other media
um even if people don't recognize like
where some of the references came from a
lot of things do come from this movie
incidentally there was a TV Movie remake
of the night of the hunter uh which came
out in 1991 and Richard Chamberlain was
in it um I haven't seen it I mean I like
Richard Chamberlain a lot so I might get
around to seeing that I never hear
anything about it so I don't know if it
was all that memorable and also starting
in 2020 and I don't know if this is
still an ongoing concern or not but
there have been rumors that Universal is
planning to do like a modern era version
which I actually might be interested to
see if it was done well and you know a
lot hinges on that obviously but you
know as as of this recording which is
you know June of June 24th June 25th I
don't remember what it is of uh 2023 uh
the classic 1955 version is actually
available to watch over on 2B so if you
haven't seen it uh you can get over
there and check it out for free and that
will do it for this flickers of fear
hope you guys enjoyed it remember to
like share and comment and all of that
for the algorithm and I'll see you guys
again on the next one bye